let's go to Omar from Atlanta Omar from
Atlanta welcome to the program what is
on your mind today
hello can you hear me yes I can
yeah so I think the other Atlanta
gentleman had a similar question it's
kind of about the Trump uh indictment
recently on these documents so my
question is is that especially since the
Espeon object has been used to prosecute
people at least the left would assume to
be heroes like reality winner and
whatnot first of all what are your
thoughts on the hypocrisy of reality
winner from the moment of arrest to uh
being released never saw foot outside of
jail and hypocrisy there with Trump and
secondly on whether or not we should be
cheering on the Espionage Act to be used
against Trump like this
I don't have any
philosophical opposition to it being
used I can it is not unique that
statutes and law
can be used in ways we don't agree with
that is that's not that's not a unique
thing and that alone doesn't make me say
this is suspect this is bad or whatever
the case may be we are we just got the
indictment we are eventually going to
see what this case is built on and we're
all going to be able to sort of Judge
for ourselves whether the Espionage is
correct or incorrect now I think it's
important to say Trump is not accused of
spying for another country a lot of
people are hearing the word Espionage or
Espionage Act and assuming certain
things that are not actually part of the
indictment let's not allow the word I
mean the Espionage Act contains a number
of different Provisions if the
indictment is accurate Trump did violate
the Espionage Act doesn't mean spied for
Russia so I think it's way too it's
certainly too early to say it's
incorrect to charge them in that way
right yeah he uh he's charged with
improperly holding documents not sharing
them yeah I guess from my perspective
it's because we have that Georgia case
building up right now I would have much
preferred to see that in the Limelight
than Espionage Act violations which just
seems at least personally less tenuous
from a political perspective there's
also a number of different charges and
it's obstruction and it's a whole bunch
of different things and it's also a
false notion to say the only thing Trump
did wrong was having the documents it
actually goes much further than that and
in fact this is the point why you have
to look at what Hillary was was
investigated for to understand it's not
about holding documents
and refusing to return them yeah
absolutely yeah that's fair
all right Omar from Atlanta thank you
for the call thank you all right very uh
very direct question I like that why
don't we go next to Zach from New York
Zach welcome to the program what's on
your mind today
hi David thanks for taking my call my
pleasure
so uh my question for you is which
political figure
do you think has the biggest
differential between how serious they
appear versus how big of a clown they
actually are
let me think about this the big and it
could be it could be that they are more
or less serious than their than their
public perception right it could be
either way
I I guess so but I'm more interested in
who appears to be very serious but is
actually a very big clown ah you know
Mitch McConnell comes to mind
both his seniority and his confidence in
answering even about things he has no
clue on make him seem extremely serious
to many people
and I think that at the end of the day
he actually is a total clown so so
McConnell comes to mind I'm trying to
think who else you know the thing about
Trump is he's not serious and he doesn't
seem serious so it's like it's very
obviously not Trump you know
you can spot that clown a mile away you
know maybe Pence would be in the running
because especially next to Trump Pence
seemed so sober and serious but his
beliefs are just built on crumbling
trash you know just a dumpster fire uh
so I would put pence in the running as
well
okay I like that answer
thank you all right well thank you Zach
I appreciate it Zach from New York that
is it is actually a tough question when
you don't think about it uh super super
uh specifically all right everybody
let's take a break we will take more
calls again if I have anything to say
about it